it's day 2 in Neill gate and as usual
both sides line up on opposite ends of
the field first there's Donald Trump
doing Donald Trump you have to stand
proudly for the national anthem
well you shouldn't be playing you
shouldn't be there maybe you shouldn't
be in the country you have to stand
proudly for the national anthem and the
NFL owners did the right thing if that's
what they've done if that is the story
do you feel like you push this story
forward and you push this to a
conclusion I think the people pushed it
forward this was not me I brought it out
I think the people pushed it forward yep
another excellent hard-hitting interview
for mr. kill me give that guy a trace or
at least something to stand on you
expect that from Trump he finds an issue
and he takes the hardline stance whining
about it would be pointless he's your
uncle Uncle Sam but that didn't stop the
Pearl clutters from clutching their
pearls the racism is disgraceful if
you're a football player or whatever
they are any sports guy who has a
position to do it do it it's ridiculous
it's absurd he sounds a lot like her
Dewan right there doesn't it he doesn't
sound like the the leader of the free
world and remember how this all started
speaking to a crowd that looked like an
SEC white football crowd in 1955 calling
them sob s and saying they should be
fired in in one world other than his is
that okay America see they missed the
point the First Amendment is a right
held by every citizen against the
government but a private entity like the
NFL they own it they make the rules as
long as there's no discrimination the
NFL can mandate that teams play at high
heels and referees wear to - it's their
ball they can take it and go home and
the players can protest but they will be
penalized if it's done during a game
penalized not jailed only the government
can jail you you see the difference
players are employees at work disobeying
a rule so where are you in all of this
where you've always been scratching your
head you prefer unity over conflict you
don't mind dissent it's the dissension
where they're not need be
mind you you still love a good debate
it's why you watch the five but a
political act within a sporting event
it's like turning on this very show and
finding me and Dana playing badminton
for an hour it's not what you came here
for it's not why you watch let's be
honest seeing me in tight white shorts
is not appropriate for 5 p.m. forever or
ever that is so true Kimberly lots of
shade at kilmeade about the box and this
and that two glass houses I'm not scared
to kill me I mean I'm asleep when he's
up alright Jessie welcome back you had
strep throat we miss jr. Thank You Trump
was right I was sick of winning it was a
purely natural vacation it's okay I read
I read recently received a say that NFL
was bowing to Trump my theory is they
wanted to nip this practice in the bud
because you could start you you can deal
for anything you can kneel about
abortion or gun rights if this keeps
going it never stops
yeah I don't read reason I read The
Weekly Standard because that's what you
gave me a subscription for no one is
trampling anyone's constitutional rights
we're all employees like we are here at
Fox News there's rules yeah I can't run
wild mostly rule so you can't run wild
there's HR rules PR rules it's just the
fact that like harf couldn't get here
when she did her one more thing and take
a knee every time people would change
the channel and then the ratings would
dip and the company CEO would say can
you stop doing that and if you said no
you're fired
that's how it works wearing their Jersey
you're in their stadium lifting you're
playing for their team they can tell you
what to do or what not to do I think
it's a great idea and Trump he's not
saying anything he's not going to deport
linebackers every safeties he's saying
love it or leave it
you know it likes his country so much
it's hyperbole he can't see how anybody
wouldn't like this country at all but
the kneeling thing really hurt because
it was misconstrued they did it at the
wrong time
speak your mind on ESPN on Fox News on
Twitter on Sunday play football it hurt
jimmy'll Hill she lost her show
the Commissioner he got hit hard because
of his erratic response it hurt the
ratings networks didn't like it it hurt
the players now some of the players that
kneeled are free agents and they're
having a hard time getting resized so it
even hurt the Democrats because they
signed it against 75% of the country so
I think this is a good thing and I'm
glad they've resolved it alright Danny
you know I another argument for not
defending the NFL ban is like this is
like shutting down speakers on campus
and you're kind of like a snowflake if
you don't want them to do some of that
today and I don't feel like the
government should be telling any private
organization what they can or should not
do I mean unless it's like you know like
harming people are illegal so I'm for
private companies being able to do what
they want to do colleges are meant to be
places for free expression right most of
them get taxpayer dollars mm-hmm and I
guess you could maybe say well the NFL
shouldn't get any money taxpayer dollars
towards stadiums fine I'm for that too
but the NFL is to play football that's
not a place where you expect to have a
free exchange of ideas like you would on
your campus that doesn't make any sense
yeah it's a free exchange of helmets to
the head Murray you can't say that this
is discriminating if it applies to
everyone correct well I think what the
NFL didn't do correctly here in my
opinion is it doesn't seem like they
communicated adequately with the Players
Association before they released this
and so now there's this fight in the
public between the Players Association
who says they weren't consulted and
they're looking at it individual players
and the NFL I know they wanted to get
this out of the way before the next
season I get that but it had sort of
receded from the headlines and so if
they had really coordinated this and
come out with a more comprehensive plan
here's our here's our plan we're gonna
find players if they kneel but we're
also going to undertake these five
community activism steps that players
have asked for it seems like that would
have been a better way to move forward
and the president's comments once again
sort of throw more you know gasoline on
the fire of what is a very controversial
issue so I think the NFL could have
probably handled this a little better
and now you have people like the owner
of the Jets who's come out and said he
will
pay the fines yes if his players get
them he won't pass them along because he
wants his players to be able to express
themselves that's an interesting point
kg because then he's putting the onus if
that's the real real word it is it is
it's not a function it puts the onus on
the other owners it's the owners onus it
puts the onus on the owner so now all
the other owners got to go well the Jets
are getting it should we do it so I
don't know is this gonna get struggle
continue yes applying pressure yeah
probably a simpler term to use since you
were struggling deeply with us all right
so now I'm saying okay he's gonna go
ahead and do that what about the rest of
you you know show up pay up etc but
listen I drew President Trump on this
because you know there are paid millions
of dollars for the privilege of playing
in one of the world's greatest four it's
one that I love to watch as well
but really there is a time for social
justice and activism I love it
express yourself that's what people
fought for in this country so that all
of us can sit here and have crazy insane
opinions at the table are you looking at
me what I ain't you what I and that's
what we're here for right is to be able
to express opinions that they are paid a
job we're paid to do a job here and we
work for this company they work for
different teams in the NFL if they have
a problem with that you know
don't play then and that's what he's
trying to say I like the use of
hyperbole that was excellent Jesse you
don't like the country then you know you
can go play for the CFL in Canada Canada
right and then kneel before the Canadian
flag yeah how that working do you think
Canadians are gonna go for that and I
don't think so touch the underlying
truth yeah all of this is that everybody
I have an inkling that everybody wants
this behind him even now on Kaepernick
everybody's like okay would this wasn't
supposed to go this right I think that's
true there's a we and then well you have
people all say look we all want the same
thing we're all for America etc yeah
absolutely people want this final and I
think that's what the NFL was trying to
do
I think that they handled it pretty well
I think they're gonna have to do it at
some point might as well do it now get
it over with they had an owners meeting
move on and I think the other thing is
now that they've laid out this policy if
it continues to happen which I can't see
how it would I mean if they're gonna
nail then there's gonna be a problem
unless you're the Jets but they've laid
out the policy so now if you do it and
you get fired you're actually firing
yourself hmm and you're making a choice
yeah and it's again it's another one of
these issues Jesse that is like they
look like were you here we were talking
about Laurel and yanny
yes it's going Annie he's a yeah knee
you yeah knee it's like it's not
fifty-fifty like 8020 in this country
and I don't have a problem with people
wanting to talk about race and police
brutality that's a noble cause but just
don't do it during the time where people
are supposed to be unified under one
flag and it's fine to be all about
activism but it's all about symbols with
these people they wear the hat they walk
out of class over guns you know they do
the Black Power thing that's fine but
then when you say well what do you want
to do about it what's the solution they
go oh well we have to do something and
they don't ever really offer any
solutions and that I think that's what
people had a problem with what do the
players want what specifically are they
addressing what are the solutions to
police brutality and racism no one knew
what those were so that's why people
were upset because it just looked and I
felt really can't afford I don't think
to have a situation where they do go
another season like race and it's not
just because the ratings but there's all
sorts of different pressures lots of
different people watching different
things but also this recent decision by
the Supreme Court about sports betting
that's a much bigger issue that the NFL
needs to deal with right now so I think
I'll straight to get this over also the
brain injuries or say yes that's a
bigger issue I think long term for the
NFL and there are some players like
Malcolm Jenkins of your Philadelphia
Eagles who went to Ohio State I will
remind you the Ohio State University who
has actually put out plans and ideas for
how to work with community activists and
law enforcement he's been doing these
meetings on his own with some other
players he is taking proactive perhaps
more players should do that like he has
been doing goals last where Kimberly I
think you should focus on
actually playing football so they can
keep their job look what happened to
Kaepernick just saying he was horrendous
for the 49ers almost ruined my football
dynasty got rid of him he can kneel all
he wants now yeah I see yeah I still
feel bad about the 49ers so bright my
best team ever everybody looked up to
the 49ers we had the best quarterback
Steve Young with Joe Montana we had
Ronnie Lott great book total impact yeah
yeah all right got a shut up now I'm
talking about myself